[Musique]
tout près d'uzès serge gainsbourg
réalise pour la première fois un fils il
a recréé ici à l'univers sordide
couleurs de rouille et presque
intemporelles c'est dans ce décor
monochrome qu'un drame intimiste va se
jouer entre trois être un couple
d'homosexuels et une femme le titre du
film celui d'une chanson à succès de
gainsbourg je t'aime moi non tel moi non
plus je t'aime peut-être et moi non plus
la korité bardot jane ensuite on a fait
un succès mondial avec moi
pour la première fois dans sa carrière
de comédienne jane birkin tourner sous
la direction de serge gainsbourg
je vais bien pour lui si je tiens ça à
coeur alors c'est on est plus facilement
blessés plus facilement s'il me dit une
chose brusquement
c'est pas comme les autres cette chance
elle qui sait de manoeuvre est le truc
qui me connaît nos idées mais non tu es
toi marche pas comme ça on n'est pas
dans le film des idées je sais pas quoi
faire mais il est il
il a raison il défend personnage yves
surtout pas les facilités ou des gestes
que j'utilise une habitude il veut moins
mais vu par lui
j'ai toujours pensé assiste actuellement
si les films sont sexuelle c'est parce
que c'est là c'est ton avis c'est le
film lave va peut-être faire une choc
parce que je crois que tous les gens qui
va avoir jeté des [ __ ] pour être les
pauvres malades ou je sais pas quoi
je crois qu'ils vont sortir de l'oeuf il
meurt quand même touché parce que les
caractères sont touchantes
ils vont pas être choqué je crois pas
mais ils vont être doublées je crois
tout le monde est un peu bisexuels gaz
bourse est l'homme orchestre de ce fim
il a écrit le scénario les dialogues la
musique et il dirige la mise en scène
certains croient que je suis fourvoyé
l'un des champs couverts charest
c'est faux vous écoutez les sucettes
je te vois plus mais le dilemme sonne
c'est de la même veine que les premières
chansons
c'est d'une meilleure facture vers la
chanson s'est terminée où ça va
continuer un garçon électrique
[Applaudissements]
je crois que le suivre lui si les basses
et c'est la peinture un peu d'air
cinétique
assurément non donc c'est la résultante
[Applaudissements]
deux choses que j'ai effleuré quand la
peinture architecture la musique et la
musique de fait ce n'est pas difficile
de diriger des acteurs dont on verra
l'arrivée je crois je crois que je suis
un visuel il est inimitable ch 200
danseurs chansons dans l'est dans le
livre qu'il est en train d'écrire dans
ce film je crois pas que quelqu'un
d'autre tirer les mêmes choses de moi
peut-être autre chose mais pas la même
chose
un nouveau visage pour birkin dans ce
film où elle ressemble curieusement un
garçon
moi je laisse moins après ça je suis
manipulé par les mettre en scène pour le
bon pour le pied ont fait ce qu'ils
veulent dans le célibat je suis gay dans
les autres films c'est c'est
généralement gay mais je viens de faire
une deux avec depardieu et c'est là
qu'ils vont être plus dogmatique ou
changé mais le personnage bah c'est moi
alors après c'est un changement les
mettre en scène
mais j'aime ça j'aime beaucoup quand
même poussé bouscule un peu secouer tout
ça ça m'excite
[Musique]